all right uh sorry about this um
hello um sorry about this there's some
internet problems we have he's just
actually talking to
uh the the uh mitch president who was at
the economics department
talking how the mit can be a leader in
technologies
uh apparently good internet is not a
a part of that but anyway um so um we're
gonna play
a number of games which are standard
games and uh to measure social
preferences
you might have a lot of questions about
those eventually uh you know what
exactly do they measure how do we
interpret
certain results and so on we're going to
discuss these in the next few
uh classes and uh
uh but for now essentially i just want
to sort of
show you how these games work you can
sort of experience them
you know pretty close to what an actual
participant of such a game would
experience
one big difference of course is that
usually these games are
played in private usually you shouldn't
talk very much to your neighbor
one big difference as well is like we
can actually implement
some of these or randomly implement some
of the choices that are being made
um so and so that makes it sort of more
public than
uh uh uh uh you know
in a typical experiment so you know you
should be aware that like
uh whatever choices you may make whether
they're nice or not
uh they might actually be implemented so
uh
uh so that may or may not affect the way
you um
uh you you choose uh you should sort of
choose uh
uh truthfully or the way you'd like to
choose don't let that sort of influence
you um
too much okay so um what we're going to
do is we're going to start with the
simplest of all games which is called
the dictator game
which you can see here
[Music]
can can you guys see the game can you
join
so i try to join the game as it is
okay so the way this game works is hope
these instructions work
and by five we mean not the bank
okay sorry so the way this works is
essentially it's a split the player game
uh we're gonna figure out what's going
on with the volume because it's a
different laptop but essentially the way
this works is like you're gonna end up
with an amount of money
there's gonna be two people there's
gonna be essentially the what we call
the divider or the dictator that's the
person who gets the money
that person can decide how much money uh
he or she wants to
um share with another person who is
randomly uh selected
the amounts will be this is uh so far
entirely hypothetical so the amounts
will be here currently it's it's it's
hundred dollars
uh uh i hate to break it to you will not
be able to win hundred dollars
today um i know i know
um uh uh it's under dollars you can
essentially decide between you and a
randomly other a randomly uh selected
other person how much you would like to
give that money uh
of that money to that other uh person
okay it's the simplest of our games
there's going to be the divider and the
receiver the receiver actually does
nothing
other than just receiving money
potentially the divider is the person to
do that okay
again i'm going to show you some results
um uh uh in a bit but so one big issue
that people often have about these
dictator kinds of games is to say well
do you need real stakes or do you need
like a fake sticks and so on so what i
have here is um i have some candy
and have some apples and later um
some money we're gonna start with candy
so these are uh swiss chocolate um um
so the way that's gonna be it's like
there's going to be always 10 of them
uh so 10 is sort of like the the overall
amount that's being shared
now uh what i'm going to do is you're
going to decide as if you
were going to be selected of course i'm
going to only select one pair of people
and that pair is actually going to be
actually implemented okay and then
there's going to be 10 and sort of like
the 100
you know the percentage of the candy
that's being shared is going to get to
the other person
you should probably use round numbers
otherwise you have to sort of like share
the
uh lemons and parts i'm going to pick
number 50 so this will be
hopefully working
uh it's brian and uh jackie
so brian was the uh dictator yes the
person giving
yes object boys brian
what did brian do uh there we go so
here's your uh here's your candy um you
can
you can pick it up
[Applause]
so you should um you should uh
uh you this is sort of the issue with
the public version of this um
uh you should feel free to do whatever
um
whatever you would like uh uh of course
uh now we're gonna do the same thing i
brought 10 apples as well
um
we have uh bg whoever you are
yes and how many apples did you there's
three apples for you and seven apples
for lauren i guess
[Applause]
uh here you are
um
they're good apples
you can share them with others as well
if you like um so now um
uh now we're gonna do the typical
version of this which is money um
usually people do this with five dollars
ten dollars and so on we're gonna do
uh um five dollars now so we have to
figure out some way of sharing it
uh venmo or whatever i'm not quite sure
but you'll i'm sure you'll figure it out
book number five
i'm sorry what'd you do
i see here's the you have to figure out
some way of giving giving
uh two dollars to isabelle wherever she
is
but here's the five dollars so now um
now something that people often say is
like well
um maybe for five dollars
is that a lot of money maybe not so
we're gonna do maybe the stakes matter
and some sort of small
um uh sakes and so on people decide in
certain ways no there's not
uh i don't have a lot of money actually
this is mostly like i don't have more
cash with me so like the largest stake i
can do is twenty dollars so we're gonna
do twenty dollars now do the exact same
thing
all right how about number 80.
alvin and uh julia
what did you do very nice here you go
uh you have to figure out a way to
actually do that
um
um
now there's a couple more things that um
perhaps one wants to vary here
so one is um uh communication so far i
think you're not allowed to communicate
is that right you could not
communicate with that person so now
we're going to do is like a version
the exact same thing uh i think this
will be ten dollars but
the same but now it actually allows for
communication so now the
sender and the receiver can communicate
the receiver can sort of
try different things to like influence
perhaps the
defender in some ways of eliciting more
money
so jinkai and uh rikita uh
where are you
what's that you haven't decided no
what's that i see and what was the did
you get any message that conveyed uh
that made you nicer or no or yeah so i
was gonna keep everything to myself
i see so some communication did seem to
to help in this case so here's ten
dollars you have to figure out how to
actually now give the
uh three dollars now another thing that
you might think
uh might matter quite a bit which is um
i'm sort of like putting you on the spot
quite a bit like you know i'm sort of
like publicizing
uh uh uh you know how much money you're
getting fund of everybody
so in some sense you might want to
actually keep the 10 or you might want
to give a lot or whatever
and like but just the fact that like
showing that to everybody might
influence
your choices so we're gonna do one
version which is not quite private but
sort of close to getting private which
is like
i'm just gonna announce which team it
was and at the end of the class
uh uh you'll tell me what the outcome
was and you get the or
i guess so you you see what the other
person does to uh
with you i see so then the two of you
can just essentially then sort of split
the money
it's sort of not quite private because
the other person obviously you have to
interact with another person
uh you should keep that in mind but it's
not like everybody in class will
uh will notice it okay is it clear what
i'm what i'm asking everyone
yes so this is private to the extent
like private towards your other
classmate except for the person
uh uh that you're matched with okay
so this is again ten dollars and uh uh
this is the last ten dollars i actually
have so um
i have more candy
all right so here um where's him
here so you got the ten dollars you just
have to uh uh
find your your partner uh
who's um wizard uh yoon
okay so you have to sort of uh settle
that with her um
i'll stay out of this
okay um we're gonna do more um
and this is the last one we're gonna do
more of uh communication
perhaps you learned about kind of like
how to best communicate or or the like
uh i think in most of the remaining
rounds we're just gonna do um
uh uh ten candies or 10 chocolates
whatever
each so this one is again
[Music]
with communications you can chat and try
to figure out kind of like
perhaps as a receiver how to best
influence the
ascender
all right so let's see
by the way we can you can be repeatedly
uh uh chosen so we have um
e one
what did you do very nice of you
here yes and here's the author
um here's your
other part
these are yours yeah girlfriend
um okay so what are some good messages
or what
some compelling messages that you
received of any or maybe funny ones
yes what was that
you are lactose intolerant or the
receiver
i see i say so here's a giver that
lactose intolerant
you could have given it instead of like
the other classmate you could have also
just given it to your friend as a giver
but um
yes um what else
was there any compelling messages that
you received it actually
worked or did something
yes i wasn't deciding but the person
told me that if i tell them a joke that
makes them laugh they'll give me
chocolate
and did you yeah they gave me 40. so
not bad so maybe you need to work on the
jokes but uh
yes all right
so now we're going to choose play a
second game which is called the oh sorry
let me close this um which is called the
ultimatum game so the
so the dictator game is a nice game in a
sense it's very uh it's a very simple
game it's a very
sort of start game and very in some
sense good at capturing
sort of a form of like pure altruism
here's like your money here's the other
person
or like how much money you want to give
for that person there's no often no
communication
often it's like even anonymous and so on
so it's essentially just kind of like
how much do you care about yourself
versus like some other person
so that's very simple but when you think
about the real world situation often you
know there's interactions across people
and um uh you know the dictator game
cannot really capture that
um uh uh that well so um one of the
sort of the second perhaps most famous
or
game in this literature is what's called
the ultimatum game um
we have again sort of instructions i
think you can't really necessarily hear
the
um um the uh
narration but um you're going to be
randomly played
sort of one player each pair is the
proposer
the other is the respondent the first
thing that will happen is
sorry so there's a proposer and there's
a
turn this off there's a proposer and
there's a receiver the proposer
uh as in the dictator game proposes some
amount of money
as you see
and then the other person who is the
receiver the responder can accept or uh
reject
okay so if somebody says you know i have
10 10 10 candy if i offer you like
uh uh one you might say that's sort of
not very nice and you might reject it
or you might say actually i'd rather
have one candy than zero candy and i
accept it
and for each of these amounts you can
sort of make a choice but so the when
you are the
um uh the the the first person choosing
you sort of need to take into account
what the other person might do for
different
offers that you have if the offer is
rejected you essentially neither of you
receives anything
if it's accepted it's just implemented
as was
what the proposal was any questions on
that
okay
and we're still playing for um
uh lin chocolates
uh wise choice uh you are
so vijay you and yeah you are
um okay so we're gonna do the
um
i see we're going to play the same thing
again uh uh uh but in rotated roles
so that's usually not what people would
necessarily do because usually it would
be essentially one-shot games was very
clean in a sense of like expectations
are clear
this is a little bit just like for you
to see the other side i think this is
now
i think it is with the same person it
might just be that the
the the rolls are rotated uh i don't
know if you can see who the other can
you actually see the name of the other
person when you play or no
i see so i think it might not be the
same person
sorry i should know this but
um
yes that's you um there you go
i think she's up there um now we're
gonna do the same thing which uh
but entails communication so that is to
say now
as a receiver you can talk to the other
person you can discuss or as
a giver you can sort of discuss about
like
if i make you the software will you
accept it or not and of course the
receiver will
have some thoughts and try to sort of
make the case
of yes or no and you'll see that has a
somewhat slightly different
dynamic so again same game now except
for now there's communication you can
talk to the other person
one person is playing with a robot so i
guess you can't really
communicate sorry
um
this is just because there's uneven
numbers and uh and trying to finish up
all right so
the person gave me a hundred
did you accept i accept there you go
lucky you but uh who is it
very nice of you are you the lacto
are you the lactose intolerant no
um
all right um
um now we're gonna do the same thing
again and private just to see kind of
like whether your choices in private
perhaps
are are different from the um
so it isn't private with communication
so as in like you can communicate but
again like
it's not public just at least to your
other classmates what is actually the
outcome
of um the game i think i'm running out
of swiss chocolate so now you have to
get some
snickers instead which is worse i think
but anyway
what did you offer
oh three did you say 330.
i gave them three 3.1 chocolates uh you
have to
you guys can deal with that
uh here you go
i stay out of this um
all right um we can do one more of these
i also have um
i brought some chocolate bunnies
these are very nice bunnies so here you
go
[Music]
this is again with communication uh
sorry i was saying this was private i
guess it wasn't private so i forgot
about this
uh this is in public uh with
communication so i should
think isabelle and hannah
what uh what did you do
and it was accepted
lucky you uh
okay so now um one main thing about
these games is
when you notice this is like uh in
particular from the receivers part
there's only one action that you see for
like one realization right
so it's not very efficient in terms of
eliciting a lot of information
in the sense that like if i ask you like
how much money do you give
and i'm gonna see what you do as like
the the first mover and then
for specific realization you sort of see
what does this person do um
as a second mover instead what you can
do is we can use what's called the
strategy method
uh which we're kind of in some sense
already doing in the sense of like
the strategy method is to say like in
case a certain thing
of course a certain situation occurs and
that situation will be implemented what
would you do in that situation
and there's a positive probability that
this actually happens and so therefore
people are incentivized to behave
optimally in a sense that like that's
exactly what we're doing right now and
something to you there's like 80
different pairs that are playing and i'm
randomly just or
randomly selecting just one so like this
is already like a strategy method in a
sense i'm asking you like in case you
are selected what would you like to do
um so i'm eliciting sort of information
from like 80 people at the same time
uh while only having to pay out like 10
10 uh chocolates or chocolate bunnies or
whatever uh
at one time for the result so that's
essentially a way of creating if you
wanted to run
large experiments that's a way of um
running experiments where there are
stakes and sometimes it doesn't matter
what you choose
but it's much cheaper to do and much
more feasible to do so
now the strategy method is sort of going
um a little bit further what the
strategy method essentially is doing
it is essentially just asking you
explicitly
it's asking you explicitly as a proposer
how much would you offer so it's asking
essentially both people as a proposer
what we
each person has asked if you were a
proposer what would you do
and then it's asking each person
as a responder what's the smallest offer
that you would accept
notice if i have those two pieces if i
match two people i can play the entire
game for any realization because i know
essentially the fully contingent plan
and that way i'm eliciting way more
information than just sort of realizing
essentially for each
person i'm going to elicit both what
they're doing in both
in both roles and for the responder i'm
eliciting also kind of like for all
potential realization as opposed to just
like if you received three dollars or
five dollars whatever
what would you do okay so we're going to
do that um
uh uh right now um i guess with snickers
so now it's not clear who actually your
partner is because now it's essentially
you're choosing like for all
uh contingent plans so so um
it's not obvious what your other partner
will actually do you
are essentially deciding independent of
my partner what my partner does for all
sorts of scenarios what i'm gonna do
um and then essentially randomly you
will be matched with somebody
so um why don't you tell me two numbers
between one and sixty
two twenty three and twenty three and
fifty two so i'm gonna just pick number
23 and 52 we're going to take the offer
from
23 and then the response from 52.
and i guess you remember what you chose
hopefully
so 23 is uh
i don't know how to pronounce your name
uh adidton
how do you pronounce your name anitron
what did you uh propose
half okay and then what what did you say
50
52 uh which is uh
uh brendan so now the question is four
half if you offered half brendan what
would you actually do
yes and you also accepted it earlier and
in your round yes here you go
that's always the so essentially that's
the way this is usually implemented so
now essentially
for that specific contingency um that's
now being implemented
but now i know essentially what brandon
would have done for all scenarios
because he gave me like his fully
contingent
uh plan um we're going to do the exact
same thing again
in case this wasn't fully clear um
so i don't know actually why that group
make making groups out of this but
whatever it's
it's fine um abby
yes what did you propose
eight was that 30
50. sorry and uh what
you no uh so it was eight and
thirteen as uh uh brian
so we're good uh uh here we go
you guys are pretty nice
previous years were not that nice
all right so now we're gonna play the
third game which has been used a lot in
this literature which is called um
uh the trust game
um the trust game um
works as follows
so there is um
a person who is the um
the investor who uh uh gives some amount
of money
and so let me just okay where's the
video
supposed to be a video oh here
right so they call it like an investment
game a trust game there's the investor
and there's the
um responder the investor
oh
okay so the investor uh and the
responder
have some uh amount of money which is a
little bit contrived here but anyway um
let's assume that's true the investor
chooses how much to send this is the
investment
the responder gets the investment plus a
multiplier the multiplier here is
usually two or three and then the
responder gets essentially the
investment plus the multiplier and then
can
decide to respond and send money back
okay
so in our case i guess it's a little
tricky to do with candy but suppose the
investor
has like a 10 to start with
you can now decide out of the 10 how
much you're gonna give to the other
person
that is multiplied by three i need to
make sure you have enough candy i think
i do
uh that is multiplied by three and then
the other person can decide to send some
back okay
and so you get sort of the issue that
like essentially on the one hand you
kind of
want to send a lot to get the other
person sort of to to
to to have a lot to be able to send you
back but of course it could also be that
you send a lot and the other person says
thank you very much
and doesn't send you anything okay
okay so this is without communication
and we'll do one with communication
after that
and why don't you take these two and
divide it in those fractions that you
have how about this
so usually this would be obviously what
like uh real numbers
uh done properly no no just divided like
i think roughly half is fine
sorry this is a little tricky with these
numbers um
okay no no that we will use this for the
next
i'll keep these yes um
all right so we can do the same thing
with communication so now instead of um
now you can essentially before the first
person makes their first choice
or what before when the person is uh
making the response choice
you can communicate and talk about like
you know what you might do in the future
which may not be the truth of course
we have um jody and sarah
hi what what did you um
give and received
so that's kind of like in some sense the
ideal scenario because
the other person had a lot of faith in
their classmate
perhaps because it's in public because
perhaps because they think their
classmates are really nice
so you gave a lot to start with and then
so that was multiplied
and and then you know you actually got a
lot back which doesn't always happen uh
either so i think you can just sort of
uh whatever this number is um and uh
divide it according to
like the the actual division what it is
um
so now we're done with those games um
what i'd like you to do is so next time
we're going to
discuss in detail kind of each of these
games and sort of like if you want more
rigorous research in a sense of like
rigorous versions of this research and
trying to understand
when you do this a bit more carefully in
terms of like experimental economists
are extremely careful in their
procedures
and in their ways in which they uh
present information and so on and so
forth
so what we just were doing was kind of
like pretty sloppy by those standards
um so what can we learn from this
research that does it very carefully
and what does it sort of predict when
you think about okay like these lab
games in some sense they're
fairly contrived what can we learn
actually are they predictive of real
world behaviors
if you have any observations about
things that you have learned or thought
that were interesting and so on feel
free to share them on the forum
um anonymously if you like and i can
discuss some of the things that could be
either anecdotes about like messages
received or things that happened
uh i can then sort of like look at these
and share them with the class otherwise
i'll see you on
monday